something I thought I'd immediately get
rejected for which was like a sketch
show because again I was like a funny
smart ass Class Clown kind of guy but no
improv stand-up training at that point
right but just auditioned for mad and
then that sent me down were you
surprised when you what was your
audition process like for Mad TV pretty
epic
um Nicole Garcia was casting and like I
did a pre-read for her and it was like
just raw energy and and and
thankfully she was like I like when you
do this you don't need to do that and so
she kind of gave me an edited version
like she helped me shape it a bit came
in for producers that worked came in for
a producer Workshop where a bunch of
people were there and they like cat did
chemistry stuff put people together and
mix and match were you improvising too
not really no that's that wasn't part of
it they gave you a script from a sketch
that they had done to see
um they just basically wanted to see
your characters your impressions
and then they give you a script to see
how how you could act basically I think
you know like can you be the straight
person in a sketch and and can you you
know are you good in front of camera
kind of thing was this the first season
or when did you come on no seven season
seven was my first and you worked in
only you worked with Bobby Lee of course
got hired with Bobby yeah he got hired
season seven yes was he a nervous wreck
he was great he was funny I mean he's
one of my my favorite people to always
go on the podcast three or four times
yeah he and I like that chemistry that's
where I first met him and yeah he was
high-end he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
are you excited are you gonna do it yeah
no my favorite like my favorite Bobby
Lee Story through that because like he
and I
kind of were the only two that tested it
Network together they ended up hiring
two other performers that year but but
Bobby was the only one there with me
then and it was at Fox and this is when
the Fox TV building had arcade machines
in the lobby do you remember this like
they had the alien one so Bobby and I
hung out after the test and just played
video games for like 30 minutes
cool and they were walking past you know
these guys are still here holding up the
sides to their face eye contact but no I
I then randomly ran into Bobby a week or
two later after I'd found out I got the
job but didn't know who else did and he
was coming out of Virgin mega store all
right on this version uh me too I mean
you're yeah this would be prime
the best time the best loved a good
hanging yeah virgin mega store
um and I saw him coming out he's like I
was like hey man hey I I got it he's
like yeah yeah I got it I got it have
you used it to get laid
has nobody said the first thing of
course yes